honestly i feel like i make this video
every year but please keep watching
because it's another ces which means of
course another opportunity for tv
manufacturers to try to sell you a new
tv here are the three ways they're going
to try to get your money this year
first up curved displays you want to
know something about curved displays
they make absolutely no sense whatsoever
sure manufacturers will tell you that it
provides a more immersive experience but
only if you're sitting dead center
anywhere off to the angle and it starts
to look distorted you want to know why
because the screen is curved basically
curved displays were made because
certain television manufacturers could
make a curved display that is not a
reason for you to buy them
next up ultra high definition or 4k
resolution sure more resolution would be
better but is anybody really complaining
about the resolution of their current
televisions furthermore there's a
chicken and egg problem here there isn't
enough 4k content to justify buying a 4k
tv that may change over time but why
should you be part of the test case
then you've got this quantum dot
nonsense this is an esoteric technology
that's decades old it's already been in
some televisions but certain
manufacturers are treating it like it's
the second coming of image quality the
tv industry loves to throw really weird
terms like refresh rate and 1080i and
now they've got quantum dots to add to
the mix none of it really matters
consumers don't care and guess what
quantum dots could make your television
cost 30 to 50 percent more the next time
you go out to buy one
here's the thing about the television
industry sometime about 10 years ago we
all got rid of our crt televisions and
replaced them with plasmas and lcds and
that was great for the tv industry
because we all had to go out and buy new
tvs the problem is they want to keep
that cycle going they look at
smartphones where people are replacing
them almost every one and a half to two
years and say hey maybe they should
replace their tvs around the same rate
but you don't replace your television at
that same rate do you usually let it sit
around for seven to ten years so while
they're coming up with all these new
reasons you can keep watching me and
everything else on very good tv you
already have